oh come on what's going on
man what's up we have some trouble in
here are we having trouble in here
that's what I've heard oh God are are
you gwet County yep thank you all right
you have a tab open do I or do I not I
don't know I'm asking you who
knows okay do you have a tab you need to
pay cuz you're going to be leaving of
course okay then let's get his tab he
doesn't have one I'm going to walk he's
good you have a ride
no how are you getting home who
knows well let's let's go step outside
let's go how did you get here who knows
so why are you being so uncooperative
I'm just trying to ask some simple
questions man I just don't believe in
alcohol I don't believe in cops I don't
believe in myth I don't believe in I
believe in God show me out on a signal
28 okay well you seem to be intoxicated
from alcohol am I driving it's not what
I'm asking did I do anything wrong 104
well from what I've understood you're
threatening people which could be
disorderly conduct so then we're looking
at a violation of law do I threaten
anyone by killing or hurting anyone I
know the law okay then you understand
then you understand disorderly conduct
and public Dr I'm State Patrol you're
State Patrol I know a little bit more
than you do you have your ID do do you
need my ID you're identifying yourself
as a state trooper I want your ID sir
you don't need my ID I know a little bit
more than you
do let me see your ID right now cuz I'm
investigating disorderly conduct and
public drunk so give me your ID public
drunk did I leave here drunk give me
your ID I'm not debating this with you
my wallet's gone have a seat for me not
going
to I know I know my rights brother look
that's fine keep your hands out of your
pockets for me so how are you getting
alcohol without an
ID who knows you're in this bar as well
as I
am so fuck the mafia fuck
off it would be nice if I had a little
bit of cooperation from bro you're what
I'm about that Godly shit my last God
okay yeah so then I would expect a
little bit more respect coming from you
that's Cas I'm totally giving you 100%
respect but get my ID out of that
fucking bar do they have your ID I'm
sure I wouldn't have fucking drove here
without an
ID have a seat for
me why not why would I cuz I'm asking
you to I've not done anything to harm
you it's not about harming me
okay is he with you uh there you go I
you want all the answers in the world
right there it is I'm not taking your
phone you crazy do you have his ID or do
you know where his ID is I have no idea
you ain't going to find
it you qu acting dumb why are we having
this conflict I'm asking simple
questions it's tipical it's typical
typal I just wish y would get right with
God stay right
there what's your last name godsy g d SE
Y and Mr godsy what's your first name
William all right William what's your
birthday what's your state patrol badge
[Music]
number I'm sorry
I3 you identified yourself as a state
trooper what's your badge number I know
that's not what you said you said you
were State Patrol okay cuz then you made
a point to say that you know the law
more than me so I'm asking you if you're
a little bit more than what's your
what's going on the world more are you a
trooper are you a law enforcement
officer certified in the state of
Georgia yes sir it
does we need to go to court where's the
judge I'm sorry I said we need get your
hands out of your pockets I'm not going
to ask you again we need to go to court
where's the judge why do we need to go
to court because you're right and I'm
wrong okay I don't understand what that
has to do you're right and I'm wrong
okay so you're not a trooper you're
right and I'm
wrong 104 are you able to run 27s and
29s or
no last name is golf Oscar Delta Sierra
EET first name name is William common
spelling date of
birth you have a Georgia driver's
license I
can't Temple that's on you and everybody
else in count I'm sorry that's on you
and everybody El in wi County where's my
license where's my ID how did I get a
drink without showing my license
pretty
smartab don't fuck with
me what does that
mean are you threatening me no I'm
saying I know there's a little bit of
button right there I know State
Patrol what's your middle name William
Chad got
you I just had a birthday my son's
birthday was just fucking two weeks
before that like okay how old's your son
my son's 5 years old okay where is he
now my son's with
his his mother
okay y know I'm just making conversation
government
know what did I do wrong sir
104 well when the staff comes to me and
says that you've been threatening people
and you've been causing issues I try
threaten in there I'm trying to talk to
you and I get nothing but Stonewall
you're not being cooperative who do I
threaten in there I don't know cuz I
haven't gotten that far yet why I came
why I came to talk to you sir I'm asking
you I'm asking you who have I threatened
have I not been a Godly person since
I've been I don't know who you are and I
haven't seen you
since I I don't know you personally
I tried what's your plan what is your
plan to leave here I tried to help
someone that I don't care what is your
plan leaving here my plan to leave here
yes my plan to leave here is not even to
leave here by myself I'm going to
Uber okay I'm going to get out here I'm
going to get out get on the app get a
uber on the way I got somebody else I
only are they here that's government
shit nobody's going to fucking
understand where I'm going to wait well
listen you can't drive and you can't
walk cuz either way you're going to jail
for those so I'm trying to help you out
to get you to get you home without going
in handcuffs cuz I don't want to arrest
you any more than you want to be
arrested thank you I'm not going to
shake your hand again but I will do what
I have to do and if that means arresting
you then I will so I'm trying to help
you so be cooperative I'm being
cooperative no you have not been since
the moment I talked to you but for some
reason who is your ride home I don't
have one at this moment
Sor do you have someone you can call yes
sir call them right
now have to wait for what you get off
the phone I'm not on the phone and
they're not talking to
[Music]
me last chance to make a phone call
still came even find my ID when I walked
in here I'll handle that in a minute
that's not my concern right
[Music]
now who was he threatening or what was
he doing uh he was just being loud
aggressive like talking like he's
speaker for God and all this stuff but
he walked
in Prett he was drunk when he came in
yeah she said that too he came in here
to meet our friend Katie who's up here
all the time is that who that is over by
the car with him she has pearls and the
pretty B and Stu I think so brunette
yeah yeah okay yeah he was sitting
smoking
[Music]
we pretty sure he had a beer while he
was here so what was he doing that was
being
aggressive just the body language he
didn't get in anyone's face he didn't
touch anybody slam down the glass A few
minutes later I sit right there he was
talking about someone in a blue shirt he
was getting really dressed talking to
her about it she like no you're not
going to be he didn't do anything
arrestable but like he's also either
about to Uber home or I don't
know is he calling for a ride no he's
calling his sister and wants me to drive
home and I don't want to fucking Le you
are you would you please I'll buy you a
drink when you get back how about that
okay is your car house he in fucking
stock fridge oh
[Music]
gross
like I mean you could take him you could
take him to Waffle House or racetrack
Quick Trip a racetrack's right down here
and he can wait for a ride he just can't
stay here well his car is here that's
his car that he drove here oh so he
drove here she couldn't even take him
home cuz then she wouldn't have a way
back cuz she could taken his truck right
un you weren't down in Stockbridge
earlier your car home my house
yeah that's we were here he was talking
about how he's got enough money to buy
everybody in the bar drink so he's got
enough money to BU an Uber to
from I hate that that's what it is it's
like people will start shit and then be
like I got more I could buy everybody in
here a drink like smooth it over and
then go into God stuff that's the
pattern every
time hey so this guy um he's intoxicated
he's in the passenger seat of this car
here okay um he's I got a report that he
was being aggressive and he needed to go
so I started talking to him he's been
uncooperative the whole time tried to
say he was
GSP um
drunk very strong possibility we may
have to fight him not yeah yeah uh but
when I walked over here just a minute
ago to check on him cuz he's supposed to
be calling an Uber he's over here
pissing in a bottle Sound Outside the
car he was standing outside the car
leaning inside the car but he's going to
go for public drun um or or disorderly
conduct I can do that on a citation um
but so you would like us I do need
somebody to transport yes if y'all can
help me figure out the citation part of
it I'll do a c a uh
a CT and
a I am not so we can work that out in a
minute but uh I am going to have him
step out
and um who's who wants to transport for
me okay um if you want
to okay all right fair enough thank
you all right William step on out for me
please pleas oh sir come to the back of
the car oh
sir you are going to be placed under
arrest for disorderly conduct tonight
okay
okay can I to the yeah you're on to your
phone sir I'll
be can you please not do this no he's
he's going to go to jail tonight I sat
in my car and the problem is my my
biggest issue well I've got many issues
but what sealed the deal was you out
here in the parking lot in a
familyfriendly establishment peeing in a
bottle that's that's unacceptable could
even you could have asked but you didn't
go to the bathroom you could have asked
but you didn't you came over here it's
indecent you're
intoxicated we could go and charge you
with more things but instead I'm going
to do disorderly conduct and solve the
problem for tonight fair
enough is thank you ma'am who who is
this I'm talking
to he has a he has a special needs son
and I know that doesn't make an excuse
for what he's done but can you please I
live in Henry
County iise he won't get out of
his he's been a problem since the minute
I started talking to him um he has not
been Cooperative uh he to identify
himself as a state patrol officer um and
but he he is going to jail cuz that's
where he needs to be tonight uh based on
his behavior so um you I can't imagine
they're going to hold him too long I
don't know what the Jail's policy is
anymore um it may be that he has to so
up first but he will be at the gwet
county jail if you want to pick him up
from
there okay um officer please I I'm I
mean I'm begging you no he he's going
he's going to jail tonight I tried to
give him every opportunity to be
cooperative uh with me so that we didn't
have to go this route and I even told
him I do not want to arrest you but I
will if you make me and he made me uh so
he is going to have to go to jail
tonight um officer I just I know that
this is your job and I know that he's
wrong but if he goes to jail tonight his
special needs son I don't know what's
going to happen uh where is his son
because he wouldn't tell me that
he his son is is his son will be with
him tomorrow but he lives with me he's
he's he's going through a lot of a lot
of stuff and he's not
100% I promise I will be
there it's already too late he's in
handcuffs I've already told him he's
going to
jail do this I don't know what's going
to happen to his son well I I can't I
can't that's not my responsibility and I
I sympathize with you and not sympathize
with him but he he's here and he's
indecent and he's drunk in public
causing problems and he has been
uncooperative from the get-go so my
hands at this point are tied he sealed
the deal on that um and I and I hate it
for everybody but I have to do my
job I understand um so will he stay in
County through the night it's possible I
don't know what their policy is if he's
intoxicated uh my guess is he may Mal
off to them like he did with me and uh
if so they will probably put him in
solitary confinement until he is sober
to book him in if they do that it's
going to be he'll be there all night and
won't be booked in and ready for release
until sometime tomorrow and he'll he'll
be able to post I guess his own fail to
get out I I would imagine so but that'll
be something that he will have to take
care of um at the jail that's not
something that I
know uh much about because it's a
totally different department it's a
different uh it's a totally different
issue I'm um will his car be okay there
CU I don't know where the the other
there's another set of keys in in his
car I think I don't know if I mean if
you want to come here I'm here until
1:00 a.m. you can get the keys from me
but if if you don't show up before I
leave I have to go put them into
evidence of safekeeping and you won't be
able nobody will be able to get them
until
Monday your um what's your name officer
Sergeant Giles Sergeant Giles and how do
I find you once I get there uh if you
walk in and ask an employee for the
officer if you don't see me then they
can easily find me okay I'm sorry it
it's all right he uh he just chose the
wrong place and the wrong person to to
act a fool with so uh I hate it for him
but he sealed his deal okay thank you
sir all right thank you byebye byebye
all right here's his phone um I don't
know where my printer is I may have left
it in the last spare car that I was in
so I have you sign in on on yours okay
here's that uh where's his car keys his
sister's going to back of his all right
his sister's going to come get him from
me it's usually not bad up here no it
usually isn't well they've had some
issues the last couple months on the
days where there's not an officer but
I'm the only one who works it now so
usually when I'm here we don't have
issues
but l oh well I'm surprised he was that
Cooperative I I mean cuz he he was
trying he was trying his best to
intimidate me and he was real close to
me at one point he said don't mess with
me or something like that and I'm like
oh this is going to get ugly real this
is going to get ugly get him in but I
mean I
just last time we had one here think you
you were just showing up were you out
here on that one I know she
was and then and I guess since then
they've had two other nights where
they've had
to
uh hold somebody down until the cops got
here
of oh
really he people like jumped him so he
went after and I guess H the security
guard he was part of it but the security
guard was break
[Music]
no the lady at the end of the table that
guy was acting very vulgar to her when
she went to go to the bathroom over
there okay do we know where he is now I
she said he's not in here okay I know
it's bad that I can't
describe black guy all he said was I'm
sure your husband gives it good as I was
walking into the right okay you don't
know what he was wearing or
anything I wish I
could okay do you know if he was wearing
a hat no no hat no hat all right just
okay I'll be well we've already got
stuff started so okay I've got to finish
up out there if you see him again or it
happens again tell me what he's wearing
and then I'll deal with him but he said
that and I'm like and I'll walk over
there and see he's just hanging out went
to the bathroom and did think anything
about it I come back my phone that's
we're not going to the bathroom alone
all right I'll check it real quick
okay there's nobody over there now so
y'all are fine but just keep your eye
out and I'll be back in here once I get
done all right I appreciate it wor
hopefully I won't have to call you guys
back out but I I really thought I
thought we were going to have to fight
this guy no joke that's he he was how
big he was well I walk up to him at the
bar and I could tell he beefy guy and he
was like Hey man we having problems
tonight he stands up he's like you know
shakes my hand he's like I don't know
are we I'm like man I I knew how it was
going to go and it went exactly how I
thought so cool thank y'all